I don't even know how to start this one
this has just happened about like 40
minutes ago but Kobe Bryant has passed
away apparently passed away and
according to reports he passed away in a
helicopter crash he was well known that
he liked taking helicopter Los Angeles
to his home and this time he passed away
in his private helicopter it's been
confirmed by Los Angeles police as well
as a dreamer Janowski and everyone who
knows basketball watch says it it's true
you know it's interesting whenever a
celebrity dies it's never much affected
me ever I don't think I can ever think
of one I was like oh my can't this one I
remember being had been reading it and I
was like no and one second and I you
know your first instincts like this got
to be hoaxes it has to be this camp is
41 years old you know and then you know
you find out it's real and it's like wow
and I think for me it affected me and
I'm not being surprised cuz I was like
what am I so affected but it's not
someone I know but you know Kobe Bryant
specifically for me was uh was weirdly
enough like a mentor you know I didn't
have much mentorship growing up and I
think in my early 20s especially when I
was in the Army and when I was doing the
transition from from the military life
to the arts his audio clips his
interviews his ideas about how you
approach the game where a lot of stuff
that I used ports my personal life and
that stuff kept me going it kept me
persevering and I think oftentimes as
young men we always want to be able to
take responsibility to be able to take
on stuff and his voice was the one that
I would have to do that his ideas were
what propagated before it and the fact
that he lived by his values all the time
you know made me want to be a better man
you know so I had him and I had Patrice
O'Neal and and I think that's why his
death specifically because I discovered
Patrice after he had passed but Kobe was
still alive he was still doing new
things still reaching new heights you
know after his NBA career as a five-time
NBA champ two times final MVP you know
League MVP he left the NBA and
immediately he like I think within two
years won an Oscar for a short animated
film he'd done so he never stopped
trying to reach those other heights and
for me to see that was like okay can't
get too comfortable you know and I was
really excited to see what else he was
going to do but you know beyond my
disappointment my own I guess sadness
about this but you have to give Quinn
adults and families to his daughters who
were gonna have to you know live without
their father overall just a really sad
day yeah this is definitely the one that
probably affected me the most so if you
guys are going through it I get it and
I'm just gonna link to some video
tributes and some you know interviews
with him that I thought were really
memorable and you know hopefully you
guys if you didn't know you get to
discover and if you did know I
understand this one really sucks I could
barely even look at the camera the whole
time but just wanted to share that with
you guys